okay we'll call the meeting to order
mike any seating changes
i'm sorry representative schuett could
sit for whoever you like
perhaps okay okay
have a motion on the minutes
motion by mcguire second by schmidt
any
additions deletions or corrections to
the minutes
see none all in favor aye
any opposed
any items to be removed from the consent
agenda
see none need a motion on the consent
motion by schmidt second by bursting
all in favor aye
any opposed
motion carries
mr chairman would you like me to read
off the postponement
yeah the most we need a motion to post
phone items
8a and 9.
would yes those are the items i would
note that for 9 both 9a and 9b
gelcar will need a waiver because their
deadline to respond is before the july
meeting
there's also um excuse me the um 9 a and
b as well
oh is that what they said i missed that
thank you
okay
motion by mcguire to postpone items
eight a and nine a and b and a request a
waiver on 9 a and b
second by bursting
any discussion all those in favor aye
opposed
department of health and human services
all right this is your objection
response to uh dhhs's in-home supports
rule
i've reviewed the department's objection
response and you have my comments
already
our office received written testimony
for this objection response yesterday
and i reviewed that testimony and i
think it's important to point out that
the written testimony conflates the
medicaid state plan with the ihs waiver
and in doing so the testimony confuses
the requirements needed to comply with
the federal law after my review i do not
believe that there are any further bases
for objection
on the department's objection response
move to approve
motion by mcguire second by gray
any discussion
would it be possible to hear i know we
did receive some testimony would it be
possible to hear from those folks who
are here today
for what purpose
uh to inform the committee on those
remaining concerns
we normally follow the advice of the
staff
and it is the
um
decision of the chair whether he wants
to hear oral testimony at this stage
not today
they're here
we have a motion and a second
mr chair particularly because this
committee did do did per you know object
to the rules before i i would i think
would be helpful to hear from the public
on this issue
okay who's here from the department to
reiterate
good morning
mr chairman melissa nemeth attorney for
the department of health and human
services
okay
happy to
i don't know if you want me to address
what was in writing
or
what the committee would like for
testimony from the department at this
point
senator whitley thank you um
i i think so we have the uh the what was
provided by the department but i
understand there are members of the
public who wanted to provide input on
that so that maybe we could start with
that and then the department could
respond
your response
the department agrees with the
testimony that where they
the staff attorney's comments um and
can address the written testimony if
necessary but do not feel that it
changes substantively in any way the
department's previous response to this
matter
give us a particular question
i i
no i i would like to hear from the
member of the public and then the
department could respond to that
it's particularly because this this
committee did have so many you know
objected to it i feel like we need to
have this a broader discussion so i know
there are members of the public who want
to provide additional input and i think
we should give them the opportunity to
do so and to what end
just to hear it we don't do this just to
hear people talk
i understand that
i understand
who is here that wants to speak again
about the same thing that we already
objected to
i don't
yeah okay carolyn
thank you
thank you mr chairman um i greatly
appreciate your valuable time
here today
the
case management issue that i raised
previously has been resolved in that the
department has admitted in writing that
the service coordination we are talking
about in this rule is case management
even though it is
not identified as such
in the rule
they are bound by the
federal
statutes that govern case management
my
second issue
is the telehealth and we don't call it
telehealth
in this rule
the legislature both houses have gone
through considerable effort
to
regulate telehealth calling it remote
services in this rule
is
serves only
to
circumvent that guidance that is in
statute
i
i think it's great
that the attorneys are now going
to the delcar attorneys are now going to
opine
on the rules before this committee at
length i would caution you however that
they are not
subject experts
the waiver that that was was read has
has many subject experts available
i don't believe they were contacted and
more importantly nor were the providers
that this rule will govern and the
citizens that will be impacted
by it so to rely solely
on the
department's testimony
and
information
i believe is misguided with the
underlying principles that the committee
is charged with enforcing
um
this is a short step to going back to
the days of
you know dark rooms and suitcases of
cash
and i'll leave it at
that um i think it's important to
explain the purpose of committee staff
we are not cert subject experts that is
correct our job is to inform the
committee if there are possible bases of
objection
based on whether or not the um
rule complies with federal and state
statute
and that is what i did i did review the
waiver and all of the testimony and
um
i do not see
a basis for objection based on the rule
not complying with federal statute or
the waiver because the rule does comply
with federal statute and the waiver as i
have seen it if you can point out a
point in which it doesn't comply with
the federal statute in the waiver then i
will absolutely take that into
consideration but i have not
after my lengthy review found any point
in which this rule does not comply with
the federal law and the stat in the
waiver
mr chairman committee staff's job to
seek out public testimony on the rules
under the statute my question for the
witness is
is your claim there was no public
hearing
no sir i was at the public hearing may
may i
respond to the question that was asked
to the witness mr chair
um it seems that right now we're in a
back and forth between uh that's why we
didn't want a department
and i don't think that that's productive
yeah
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
so
you
i'm sure you're well aware that that gel
car you know can only object to the
rules based on the statutory you know
the statutory um
reasons under 541a so is there do you
believe that there is there is a basis
for objection at this point
and if so what is that one
i um i believe that there is a basis for
objection in that
uh the remote services which are
telehealth do not reference the
telehealth statutes
so the rule is not consistent with
statute additionally
in the waiver the services that the rule
is being written about is referred to
as telehealth in the waiver
and i've provided
those references
in my
testimony of a couple of days ago that i
submitted in writing
i would be very interested to learn
why
environmental mental modifications
vehicle modifications
and emergency response buttons are going
to be utilized in hospitals by children
um the department may be able to answer
that question better
after my review i believe that the the
waiver
does not restrict the
department from using the term remote
versus telehealth the telehealth
statutes apply to specific providers and
those providers are not
the same as the ones that are are
providing services under the ihs waiver
um so they're they're again they're two
they're two separate
things
representing choir yes if the remote
services included something that would
qualify as telehealth would that be
covered by the statutes that we already
have
uh yes especially if those were the
providers under that statute
thank you
senator whitley are you satisfied at
this point thank you
looking for emotion
sir you have a motion by maguire a
second by gray i believe it was a move
to approve okay
you've heard the motion any discussion
by the committee
yeah
if possible i would love to hear the
department respond to the issues raised
by the witness
thank you for allowing me to speak today
i appreciate the opportunity department
good morning
again for the record my name is melissa
nemeth i am an attorney for the bureau
of developmental services
and to speak to the point of the remote
services
the reason that the as attorney immune
is pointed out the statute that is
referenced in the testimony just it does
not apply to the providers in the waiver
that is for providers of medicaid state
plan services and we are talking about a
medicaid waiver so it cannot be the same
services that are on the state plan
otherwise we wouldn't need a waiver
so
in the providers additionally the
providers under the in-home support
waiver are not regulated by that same
statute so they do not need to comply
with the telehealth components there i
would also point out that in the rule
in the section it's 524.16
that lays out these services it does lay
out all of the parameters that would be
necessary for this service for the the
identified services to be provided in
the remote modality
including
it has to be deemed appropriate for that
individual it has to be in their service
plan there has to be oversight so all of
those elements remain but the the fact
is that the statute that has been
referenced does not apply
in the waiver agreement with cms it is
not identified that those that that
statute applies it's laid out in the
waiver what all of the qualifications
are and how that will be provided
and that's totally permissible by cms
standards
and to address the point of certain
services that were asked about in acute
care hospitals
the purpose for that for example
environmental modifications it wouldn't
be that the room in the hospital is
being modified but if the individual is
in the hospital and needs modifications
to their home prior to being discharged
while they are in the hospital this
allows that service to be provided and
billed rather than waiting for the
individual to go back to their home to
let that service be billed
and the personal emergency response
services that can include something that
for example has an app on a phone or has
an other monthly charge and the waiver
provides that
while someone that we will pay that the
waiver will pay for that monthly
maintenance fee so if that if someone
went into the hospital and this service
was not allowed to be provided in the
hospital they would lose
that maintenance of that service that's
important to them for that time period
with that i'm also happy to take any
questions from the committee
any other questions from the committee
you've heard the motion in the second
and the extended discussion
all those in favor
any opposed
one of one
okay
so
we have a no from senator whitley and
representative shuitt
and are you here for criminal records
and
thank you
okay yes sir this proposal makes changes
to no longer allow licensed exempt child
care providers
to receive reimbursement prior to the
results of their staff members criminal
records check
in order to be in compliance with
federal law
and it requires that facilities ensure
that these staff members are also so
supervised during that time
in its request for a fiscal impact
statement to the lba the department
didn't talk about any potential cost to
the providers for these new requirements
however it does sound like that the
providers can be reimbursed
retroactively if that staff member's
background check comes back clean
the department asked the lba for revised
fists
since it did need to cure this defect in
the fists
and since an amended fist can only be
sought in the case where changes
are resulting as a result of
of
notice and hearing they couldn't really
get an amended fist so they've gotten a
revised fist but
that's actually not a type of fist that
can be sought underneath 541a
so that's the remaining issue and the
committee may need to consider amending
541a to allow
getting a
fist in the case of a defect
in the
initial office but you may have
questions for the agency about this
good morning my name is nicole burke i'm
the administrative rules coordinator for
the rules unit at department of health
and human services and happy to answer
any questions if you have any
do you have a response
um so initially the fist was the request
for fist was drafted um it's actually
most likely a revenue neutral situation
however reflecting upon there could be
an extra staff person in a facility
based program most likely they're just
in two two people together in one room
versus two separate rooms however due to
it being potentially indeterminable we
did revisit that submitted it to the lba
could not do an amended fists per
attorney reeves statements
and have completed what lba referred to
as a revised fist
and did submit that with our conditional
approval
and i should state that the lba did
identify that the the costs were
indeterminable
okay questions from the committee
motion
second
motion by mcguire second by lang
any further discussion from the
committee
peter
thank you mr chairman well it was
referenced that uh the committee wanted
might want to consider amending 541a
and i think we
are at least have a word about that
it's in process now yeah it's it is not
something we can do well it's i i
understand there's nothing we can do
about it at this point the question is
whether
the amendment is in works and i'm i've
just heard it is yes it's uh we have a
list of 541a amendments that we're
working on that will you'll see in
probably the next couple months terrific
thank you
okay mr chair yes yeah i'd like to
express my concern that we're getting
creeping cost growth to our businesses
by federal regulations
and therefore i'm i object to that
principle even if this specific rule
doesn't cause a
major impact it's still
a new cost to our businesses that the
federal government is imposing on them
and i'm
opposed to that idea
your comments are noted
seeing no further questions
we have a motion in a second all those
in favor aye
any opposed
now the next rule is uh 2021-126
it's on home visiting for prenatal child
and family support services um this was
actually
the i have no comment on the rule tax
this is consent in terms of the rule tax
um it is on your agenda however because
um if you open up the rule
and scroll past the notice you'll see
the fiscal impact statement and there is
a rather significant fiscal impact um it
does appear that
that fiscal impact is due to
the
the statute change
um the the cost essentially per unit has
not changed it's just the people that
would be eligible and the amount of time
they would be eligible for has changed
but since it is a rather significant
impact we thought you may have questions
for the department
again for the record my name is nicole
burke administrative rules coordinator
for the rules unit at department of
health and human services
and again here to answer any specific
questions you may have and with me is
the attorney for the unit
questions
motion
move to approve
motion by lying second by gray
discussion
seeing none all those in favor aye
any object any objectors
opioid abatement trust fund and advisory
commission
okay yes sir um this proposal will adopt
rules um basically to set up an rfp
process for the distributions out of
this trust fund account
the agency has filed an amended of
conditional approval request
after our discussions with them this
monday around the need to have some
broad scoring criteria in the rule
for
scoring these
rfp applications
there's just one issue remaining and
that is on the the first page of the
rule and that is that the originated
statute was effective in 2020 and so the
committee may have some questions about
the delay in bringing forward of these
rules
good morning allison zeno administrator
of the administrative rules unit for the
department of health and human services
rsa 126 a 83 through 86 became effective
uh 7-1 20-20
at that time the department of justice
had to form the commission
to start working on these rules
which in turn
a work group was formed between doj and
the department
where they started drafting
crafting
and editing these rules
and
met multiple times and really just have
kept going the best we could um also
while in the middle of the pandemic
presenter mcguire
thank you mr chair has have any uh
grants been
awarded
um i can have uh attorney maria reinman
um if she'd like to come and answer that
question she would know she's shaking
her head so i presume that means no
okay
so no thank you thank you
mr chair
yes
so question
senate bill 275 passed with deals with
this fund as well and the commission and
my question is to these rules or are
they in any way in conflict with the
current law that was signed by the
governor just recently
so senate bill 275 passed the house
passed the senate was signed by the
governor just recently regarding this
exact topic the the fund and the
commission my question is are the
changes in that bill
now law
in conflict in any way with the current
rule you're putting forward
i've also been uh heading up the uh the
opioid litigation i don't think that the
change in that statute will uh will
conflict with these rules the changes
were fairly minor
to to change the census numbers the
original legislation had the 2010 census
numbers for distribution to those 23
subdivisions who had filed lawsuits uh
so it changes it so that we use the most
current census figures it also adds a
member to the commission
and
and expands
very slightly the types of approved
uses for opioid abatement funds that can
be can be authorized under the statute
so i don't think that it it changes that
in any significant way
thank you
move to approve
motion by lying second by bursting
discussion
all those in favor
aye any opposed
sanitary production and distribution of
food
yes thank you uh my name is
attorney rebecca ricard i'm the newest
attorney here um with the joint staff
committee excuse my mission here but let
me introduce rebecca ricard to everyone
present my apologies i should have done
that at the start of welcome
welcome her to joe carr
yes
uh thank you very much and i apologize
this is my first meeting so i should
have brought this to the committee's
attention initially um we are asking
that this one be postponed as well
the
agency did submit a conditional approval
that did address a number of the
staff's comments but there were still a
couple that need to be worked on
so the agency has requested that this be
postponed to the next meeting in order
to file an amended conditional approval
to address those additional
any discussion all those in favor
any opposed
all right
all right the next rule is uh 2022-18 of
the insurance department
um this
rule is based on the naic model
so it's going to look a little different
than some you know
rules you normally see
that is a statutory exemption in 541a my
only comment is on page 44 of the rules
um it appears to
the the
the conflicts with other laws section of
the rule
um
the department may have a lack of
authority here because it appears that
the
the rule is allowing
the rule to supersede state statute
um i also want to note though this is
the exact same language that came
through
in 2012 and we did not have a comment on
it then so this this has been the rule
i think for 10 years now
um
but yeah you may have questions i think
the department may be able to explain
better
and as commissioner nicolapolis here
okay
no
how about now there you go there we go
okay
uh good morning yes so yep so um my name
is heather silverstein i'm general
counsel for the insurance department
uh this rule is based off a model
regulation
it's a long-term care regulation from
the national association of insurance
commissioners with standing ic
and the reason that the regulation is
written in this way and that we also
write our regulation this way is because
long-term care
uh products insurance products are
different than major medical insurance
products and so all this rules
is stating is that the the
statutes and rules that apply to major
medical products do not apply to this
particular long-term care uh product and
how they review um benefit determination
so let's say a a company denied the
benefit there's a procedure that you can
appeal internally and externally related
to those decisions and for long-term
care you go it's related to 415d which
are statute and this rule 3601 now if
you were in major med the way that you
would appeal would be through
um
the external review process which is a
different rule ins 2700 so that's all
this rule does is it's just saying these
these statutes and rules that wouldn't
apply they don't apply
yes
in that case i think that you should
more clearly reword that section so that
instead of saying
the provisions of this section supersede
the
statutes
the the statutes do not apply
which is
which if you're correct
is a more
appropriate way to say it you can't
override a statute in a rule
true and like i said we just follow the
model language and so that's all it's
just saying if the clear it's clarifying
that this is not we're not in a major
med product so we don't apply those
rules
fine yeah um i
i'd like to move to make a conditional
approval request
okay
um would you
prefer the sentence be changed around so
it has you know rsa 420 and the
citations
um do not apply to
yes
you can't you can't say in a rule that
you're superseding a statute you can say
that the statute does not apply
which i would agree with but you can't
say you're superseding it
did that work for the department um the
only thing that i would just have
concerns about is that the change in the
statutes um
we're just trying to i want to make sure
that it's clear that this that the
provisions for review are in ins 3601
and that practitioners and other people
looking at the rule would understand
that these major medical
statutes and rules do not apply so
that's my concern i guess i would have
to look at the the how you would say
that they do not apply i think that
should be clear enough
yeah i think that i think do not apply i
would
feel more comfortable with
if you wanted to do it that way
i do
um so i'm just going to read this whole
sentence so it would read
rsa420j5a
rsa420 j5b rsa420j5c
and ins2703
do
not apply
for external review requirements to
these rules
yes okay okay it's not too much sorry
shall not apply
to this this to a long-term care
insurance policy
is what it really is
right those are statutes that are not
though like i said they're not upset
which is what the rule is about senator
gray oh that was what i was going to say
is that thank you that provision should
be added in there that they don't apply
too long care
and that makes it clear which is what
the attorney said at the beginning of
her
testimony so you can read it back today
sorry it would be rsa420j5a
rsa420 j5b rsa420 j5c and ins
shall not apply for the purposes of
external review requirements for
long-term care
insurance yes and that would be the that
would be what would exist in this
particular provision in i under conflict
with other laws yes that would replace
it that's what you're saying right yes
yes do not represent schmidt
unfortunately
do not apply or shall not apply
you think shell if we say do not apply
you no longer have a rule there is no
requirement in place so it needs to say
it shall not apply or shall not be
applicable shall not be applicable
that's why we have lawyers
thank you
motion is for conditional approval
all those in favor
aye
any object
and i'll send the department a letter
with all of that written out so you can
see it before great thank you
department of safety
mr chairman
we also have an emergency rule from the
pharmacy board item 8b
okay
let's do this
let the safety people okay
this is an emergency rule put forward by
the pharmacy
board
as some of you may have read in the news
there is a severe shortage will
worldwide for contrast media for ct
scans
the
the medical
the medicine that's used to
intravenously to create a contrast so
the ct will work
is in very short supply
what the pharmacy board would like to do
in these rules is to allow for
single dose vials to be used for more
than one patient because there's more
medicine in the vial
than is necessary for a single patient
this way they can use that towards a
second patient and
eventually
lower the amount
or
i'm sorry to
give more people these this medication
that's it
okay that's an emergency rule
and there does seem to be a basis for
the emergency
good luck
thank you
now department of safety
okay yes sir um
this proposal makes changes to the rules
covering the installation and use of
ignition interlock devices
the agency has late filed a conditional
approval request and so first the
committee needs to vote to accept that
before we can discuss the um the issues
that remain
hello
by grace second by
lang
all those in favor
any opposed
okay so there are five items to bring to
your attention the first one is on page
two at the bottom of the page
here the rule says that the form can be
found on the referenced website but it's
not there yet in discussion with the
department the department states that
the
form will be posted after gel car
approval
the next item is on page six
and there's a similar comment also on
page seven
so
here the rule requires that the device
be set at point zero two zero
uh testimony has been submitted stating
that this is a violation of a
legislative intent because rsa 265 a 37
roman 3 a
but that statute actually says that
there will be penalties for a person
if their breath alcohol concentration is
over .025
it doesn't require that the device be
set at .025
so it would seem to be a policy decision
whether or not to set that device lower
since i didn't find anything in the
statute that would affirmatively require
it to be set at a specific
you know
level
so you may have some questions for the
department about
that or i can move on to the next point
what you should be there already
all right thank you
my name's marta moziani i'm representing
the department of safety i'm an attorney
in the legal unit and the
rulemaking allows the commissioner to
set forth the model the the
specifications for the devices and in
the rules the department has
incorporated by reference the nitsa
model specs for the device which sets
forth a alcohol set point of 0.020
for and that does not ring up the user
as a violation but it just stops the
vehicle from starting so
at point the alcohol set point is 0.020
but the violation set point is 0.025 so
if they blow in the device and it it
reads 0.025 or more the user has failed
and violated the program
what happens if they
blow up
0.21
it records and it sends that data and it
just stops the vehicle from running
until they're they're able
to
that sounds like a penalty to me
it's not a penalty just doesn't start
the car it tells the the person who they
shouldn't be driving at that point
until it's dissipated
next
okay so um the next comment is on page
nine and um we received testimony uh
suggesting that the rule language uh
should be amended
and it says that the device
because
it was a little confusing but i think
that the testimony seemed to be saying
that at this point in time the device
would already be installed however this
section is about ins
initial installation of the device
so when looking at that testimony it
didn't seem that the um the changes that
were suggested would be appropriate
since the device this is about initial
installation of the device
i didn't know if you had any comments
you know for the or any questions for
the department about that but it really
did seem like that this whole section is
about initial installation
it is about the initial installation and
it is um
in order to ensure that the person who
is having the device installed has
demonstrated proficiency by blowing
three times and passing
before they
they get the certificate
yes thank you it
i agree that it the sequence seems wrong
that this is obviously to check out
after the device is installed and you're
demonstrating this proficiency which is
which is fine but that does this mean
that the
interlock service provider will then
immediately remove the device if they
fail that the test if they can't blow
three times
they shouldn't they
if they can't pass it yes i believe
that's the case but i've got the dmv
here
um
would
this is
this is uh bob keller who's currently
the acting administrator of the um
bureau of financial responsibility in
the acting direct i'm sorry the
deputy director of the dmv mike todd
so at the initial installation uh
sorry
sorry the initial installation
we're looking for that proficiency
nothing states that it needs to be
installed in their vehicle at that time
to pass those tests
we're just saying that we want to show
them proficiency so i know that the
providers do have some test models and
other devices that they can use to have
the operator demonstrate that
proficiency so that they can show that
they can safely operate the vehicle
before they leave that appointment that
garage
so this is a this is a test of the
equipment
no it's a test of the person
okay
right to ensure the the operator knows
how to use the device and be able to
operate the vehicle
okay
okay so the next issue is on page 11 and
here the rule says that a person's
driving privileges can be suspended
when there's a
consistent pattern of failures to pass a
breath test
and
you'll see my comment i'm agreeing
initially with the testimony that was
submitted
that perhaps the rule needed to have a
bit more firm language but after talking
with
a staff from the department
i think it probably should stay as it is
because it was explained that this
language is meant to capture a pattern
of behavior
so say if a person
is can't pass a breath test every friday
night
then that would be a pattern that the
hearing officer would need to know about
and would be a pattern that
that they would need to take in
consideration for violations but i'm
sure that the department can't explain
exactly what is
contemplated by that language
thank you um
safc6512 sets forth the
violations whether a person who has
violated the laws the rules
would incur an extension of the ignition
interlock device
or a actual suspension of the driver's
license and it also is escalates in
terms of the number of violations that
they have
increases the the extension and or the
penalties this rule so so
that rule already addresses the failures
of the breath test whether it's one or
two
this talks about the actual pattern and
that is taken straight from the statute
takes 265 a 38
roman numeral two
um
talks about being able to
bring someone in for a hearing for uh
showing a consistent pattern
and i think that in speaking and i don't
want to speak for
mr blaisdell here but um in speaking i
think there was some concern that this
was
about the
vendors as opposed to the user
this is a requirement on the user
okay what else do you have okay so i'm
finally on page 16 there's a note
just an informational note regarding the
use of the rules citing to rsa 541
rather than 541a for appeals and
normally individuals must avail
themselves of the appeal process in 541a
unless the statute specifically states
otherwise and in this case the safety
statute does state otherwise so that is
the reason for that citation
okay so we have testimony from
consumer safety technology
you support the bill
with changes
correct good morning mr chairman members
of the committee for the record my name
is robert blaisdell
and i represent consumer safety
technology out of des moines iowa they
are one of the registered vendors with
the state for the ignition interlock
by way of background
i've been involved with this issue since
the early 2000s i've been a part of
every single legislative hearing
as these statutes have been changed over
the years
i have a pretty good idea what the
legislative intent has been
and after talking with the department
earlier this morning um i'm going to
just focus on just one section of our
comments i believe
my first section in my third section
we've essentially worked out
which is going to be fine with a much
better understanding and i appreciate
that conversation so i'm going to focus
uh this morning just on
page nine uh that i'm aware of fixed
dated um
text of may 26 2022 in its uh safc
6507.01
[Music]
we believe that uh this proposed
language in in rule creates an
additional
um
an additional uh condition beyond
legislative intent
um we believe that in
in rsa 265 a colon 36 roman numeral one
in roman numeral 1a it clearly states
the legislative intent is is that this
device shall be installed
this creates um sort of a putting on the
breaks
of wait a minute no it's not going to be
installed if
if they can't happen to to pass three
breath tests
um
a couple of things we believe that goes
beyond the legislative intent
um
clearly stating that it shall be
installed and secondly um you know some
people can be very savvy and if they
don't
like the fact that this device is being
mandated upon them to install in any
registered vehicle that they have
they can simply go in and
not not pass the three tests
and guess what happens that that device
as as it says no interlock service
providers shall install a device in the
vehicle of a user who is unable to pass
the breath test
um they're walking away that day with no
ignition interlock
on their car or cars
and
we don't believe that's in in in the in
the public interest because this person
has been deemed
a concern of public safety
and this device shall be installed
so again we just believe that this is a
needless loophole i believe is
unintentional
and we have concerns about that going
beyond legislative intent and i'll be
happy to answer any questions
thank you mr chairman so um
you indicated in your initial remarks
that you had some conversations i
believe this morning and you worked out
some of the issues
uh and did you discuss this particular
aspect as well we did and what is the
result of that
uh colloquy the result of that
representative is that we agreed to
disagree
very respectfully it was a wonderful
conversation
we just happened to not
happy for both of you
but
where are we going to go from here is
the question
well my understanding um is that um
it's it's up to you all to determine if
this goes beyond the legislative intent
um about creating an additional
condition
um clearly i think that this statute
states that it shall be installed period
that's what you all as the legislature
has determined
these rules are saying wait a minute no
it's not going to be installed if they
don't can't do but i i take your point
and i understand and now we have to hear
from our attorneys what they think
thank you thank you
so i'm i'm looking at 265 a 36 the two
sections that he's
referenced said any person who is
convicted of driving while
suspend under suspension or revocation
resulting from a dwi fence
shall be required by the court to
install an ignition interlock device in
any vehicle registered to that person or
used by that person on a regular basis
so it does say that it shall be
installed
i do take his point that this could
create a situation in which the device
isn't going to be installed at that time
i don't know whether or not and maybe
the department can speak to it whether
or not
it would be installed at a later time or
if there's any provision if a person
continuously
you know flows too high of an alcohol
concentration and can't have the device
installed don't know what happens at
that point so perhaps the committee may
need to have those questions answered
mike
mr chairman
committee members
it would seem i understand the
legislative intent is to have the device
installed i would think that
with that intent is that the device
actually work for the person that's
required to use it
go ahead i would think the intent is
that someone who can't safely blow less
than 0.2 or 0.25
not be driving
and so the point is to have the ignition
interlock device installed so that that
person can't drive
whether or not they they can manage the
technicality of doing it once
doesn't exempt them from you know not
wanting to have
you know a car they can drive without
showing that they're not drunk
may i mr chairman this isn't about uh
it's been a little misunderstanding here
this isn't about whether or not this
individual
um passes
uh meaning whether or not their car is
going to start or not this is simply
about
um instructing the individual
i mean hopefully they're going to show
up and they haven't been drinking
this is about the individual having
three successful tests of they can do it
it's it's a it's a device that has a
little tube that you blow into
um and it's it can get a little bit of
it's it's not rocket science it's very
simple you blow into it but it's
obviously different for those who have
never done it before
um so they just blow into it and the the
the guts of the device has to determine
um the breath sample about whether or
not there's any alcohol detected or not
so this is not about determining if the
car is going to start and this is about
whether like training the person this is
what you do this is how it's done yeah
if i could um
so it seems like the issue would be on
the language where it says no interlock
service provider shall install a device
in a vehicle of a user who is unable to
pass the breath test but i mean at that
point if they're there and they're
getting it installed and they can't pass
the breath test i mean they can't drive
right so
i'm not really sure and i don't know
anything about the legislative intent i
haven't been involved you know in those
bills but it would seem to be that you
know like mike said part of the intent
would not be for this person to be able
to drive even after installation
yeah this is apprentice
this is a conundrum go ahead sir
you gotta use your mic
thank you representative switch so
they show up
they can't pass this test so the device
can't be
placed in the vehicle so what happens at
that moment is law enforcement called do
they drive away
like what do we do because i think the
point is to have
in the best case scenario them show up
taking this seriously um passing this
test putting this device in and then
following along the law so that they're
not driving well intoxicated but if they
can't get past that point what do we do
because that seems to be the issue
all
right what do we do okay so i'm first of
all um the department may have a
different answer than me but i am not
aware of anybody that's that's not able
to to use a device this is um this is a
very simple simple thing where you just
blow into a tube
so so if my my our whole concern is is
the potential savvy person
who purposely does not want to pass
this test who doesn't want this device
on their vehicle
that's the the issue that's created
beyond the legislative intent so to
answer your credit what what happens
currently right now my understanding is
that these people are instructed on on
how to use the device
and
they go off on their way
i have not heard of anybody that has not
been able to to perform this simple
breath test
okay department
yeah department thank you
thank you
thank you so
one of the things that i
i'm not going to take it in exact order
so i think i'm going to try to respond
in total here but 265 a
36 1 was cited but the second part of
that paragraph also says that a
certificate proving installation of the
device
shall be provided to the dmv as a
conditioned precedent to reinstatement
of the individual's license to drive so
they shouldn't even be driving
they wouldn't have their theirs
their suspension lifted in order to
drive until we got that certificate of
installation
um so
so
right right and so
they have to have it on their car
otherwise they it the car can't operate
and they can't drive that's the idea it
has to be foolproof
that i mean i get it that they they have
to be instructed it's a simple procedure
i've had it explained several times uh
and
it's a simple procedure and the device
is on there car can't be driven without
and without the device having given the
the go sign it this is this i mean
people could be using someone else's
vehicle whatever car that they regularly
would use is the vehicle that has to
have that installation that device
in addition
um
what we i think the dmv would say is
that there have been instances in which
individuals might say that they were not
instructed properly on how to use a
device and that's why there's a failure
of sorts when they're brought in because
once
once that device is put in if they
somehow fail they are rung up
and so that is to to ensure that the
individual knows how to and we know that
they know how because they've had three
past
breath tests
right
it's not only the case as i understand
it that they get rung up as you say but
the vehicle won't operate you cannot
drive the vehicle it you won't start
correct at 0.020
mr chair
tim
thank you so i i think it's pretty clear
you got to get the device installed
first before you get your suspension
lifted then you get suspension lifted
then you have to use the device on the
drive every single time i don't have an
issue with that process it seems to work
clear my issue is the 0.20
because the statute
specifically says 2-5
is where penalties start occurring and
so yet to represent a mcguire's statute
we're imposing a penalty at a lower rate
by saying you can't drive your car
at 200 which isn't what the statute says
so i'm that's my only concern is the set
point of the alcohol content at 2 2 0
which is below the statutory as i look
at 265 a 37 it talks about penalties and
it talks about concentration points of
0.25
025025025 throughout the entire thing
and yet somehow now we've set a new
standard of 0.20 and said you can't
drive at 0.20
so and somehow the agency thinks it has
the authority to do that
that's my only concern
so the
violation set point is when somebody is
rung up in terms of a a bringing being
brought in for a hearing having an
extension of the
order itself
0.020 is the alcohol set point that when
the device reads that 0.020
the vehicle won't start it's in the the
person will not be
considered having violated it's just a
a
preventing the car from starting until
the alcohol level is lower
that is the model recommendations from
the feds it is the industry standard
that was um that we've been advised by
the other vendors as well um what what
265 a 37 talks about is the violation
set point
senator gray
i agree with the the people who are
suggesting that we need to go back and
have a legislative solution to the
0.020 and 025
right now i don't believe that
the statute
you know supports what you're doing
uh taking away the the access to the
vehicle at that point
and i'll be voting
uh that way
unless the
provisions
changed ahead diane
thank you mr chair
is it not true that
the person is under suspension
and is not supposed to drive their
vehicle until the device is installed
therefore the
the point up to the level of a violation
they the only penalty is that they
cannot drive and they're under
suspension anyway correct
i think what you're asking is unless
they
have the device installed
they would their license would be
suspended
and once they have the the dmv has the
certificate of installation of that
device
they would be able to operate as long as
they were in compliance with the program
mr j again just just to
clarify if if i heard that right was
again their license once they've gotten
the device installed in their car their
license status is no longer suspended or
revoked their license status is valid at
that point the only condition and term
is that they have to breathe into the
breathalyzer before the car will start
is that accurate
they have to comply with the program
which is have an interlock device
installed and then before prior to
starting the car blowing to the breath
too to make sure
so just as a background i'm a former
police officer probably the only person
here was certified as a breathalyzer
operator so i understand the process and
understand the interlock system but
again my concern to it senator gray is
that the department's setting a standard
that's
i'll say greater than what's allowed by
statute in other words they're they're
adding conditions that aren't allowed as
far as i can see by statute anywhere
um
you're allowed to create a program and i
understand your difference is that you
don't think that not starting the car is
a penalty but i would say that starting
the car is not being able to get to
where you need to go would be a penalty
or or a problem for a citizen and where
the state's imposing that problem
and and because of a standard that isn't
set in statute so so if i could respond
the the department is is provided the
rulemaking authority to approve the
ignition interlock devices and we've
incorporated by reference the federal
register standard
for the model specifications for these
devices which has an alcohol set point
of 0.020
this was also i believe the
recommendations of
some of the public comments that we
received from the vendors
so the conflict is between the federal
register and new hampshire law well i
don't
i
i respectfully disagree in the sense
that the violation
[Music]
the fact that the device just says okay
you're you're pretty close to to being
rung up
um with a violation which could extend
or suspend your driver's license
depending on how many violations you may
have had in any period of time
and it it's just going to delay your
movement
until your alcohol
level comes down
while while a .025
is you're going to be found in violation
of the program
mr chair just what what are our options
at this point
there is a conditional approval uh
request
that has been submitted so
basically the committee could
approve the final proposal approve the
conditional approval or preliminarily
object
and there would need to be a basis for
the objections such as legislative
intent
you could also postpone and um
the committee or i'm sorry the
department could come back with a
amended conditional approval
yeah they could come back with amended
conditional approval um just to go back
to 265 a37
um
roman 3a i mean this statute i did not
find any place that said exactly what
the device has to be set at and the
statute does state that upon
satisfactory proof that a person who is
restricted by law to drive
only a motor vehicle equipped with an
ignition interlock device has attempted
to start a motor vehicle equipped with
the device while having an alcohol
concentration of .025
or who fails to retake the test so it's
talking about the penalties associated
if they try to drive with that
concentration didn't see anything again
that states what the device must be set
at
can i make a movement to postpone second
emotion to postpone sorry
most important in a second to postpone
discussion
all those in favor
aye aye
any opposed
okay you're postponed
passenger tramway
safety board we don't have
correct they have not submitted their
objection response yet okay um one other
point mr chairman
on three of the uh hhs rules well two of
them there were conditional approvals
and one there was the amended
conditional approval the committee
approved each of those i just for the
record i wanted to make sure that the
committee was approving the conditional
approvals or amended conditional
approvals
safe to say yes
thank you
also continued meeting
we can dispense with the continued
meeting
and we have no other business for you
we have nothing under our business
meeting is adjourned
you